the question remains why is it that we
human beings are so obsessed with the
notion of the absolute why is that the
absolute is so much and will always
remain alive whether we call it God or
science or styling or whatever what is
the absolute nobody's searching for the
absolute that would know whether if it
bit them they wouldn't know what is the
absolute sorry to be difficult but have
you ever seen an absolute in your life
how can you say I mean how would you
read how would you recognize that have
you met it it's not that people what
religion is about and the thing you
think is explanations for the nature of
the world in which we live and that's
what religion religion is about and many
of our silly ideas are really
explanations for things that we don't
understand now I'm trying to talk to you
like which I'm not a naive scientist and
I'm trying to beat you on your own
terrain let me propose to you a
paradoxical statement if you ask today
majority of people they would have
probably said in Europe yeah in some
sense we are Christian then if you ask
them but Christianity means a certain
set of thesis do you remember do you
sorry do you really believe that 2,000
years ago a guy was walking around in
Palestina who was God 15 percent they
did in Slovenia maybe we are a pervert
at night you know what I mean read the
book by I think it was pervy done okay
did the ancient Greeks believed in their
God where he demonstrate that it's clear
that belief in practice means something
else they were not stupid they didn't
think if you climb on the top of Olympus
you would see their I don't know she was
growing Aphrodite or whatever it's not
it was something much more mysterious
it's more you know the paradox of belief
and here I think you should search for
absolute is that first we
unconditionally want meaning absolutely
give you an example where I hope we will
agree and I think it's nice example of
ideology today why do we eat organic
apples and buy them I think most of us
know probably this is to a large extent
[ __ ] but it makes us feel good you
buy organic apples so my god I'm doing
something great I'm helping mother
nature it's a big solitaire movement
with no sorry I don't buy neither do I
know I like phonetic nice I want no
sorry but let me go on very briefly so
that I stop you so but at some point you
know what for me nonetheless the problem
and I appeal here again to you in all
this listen let's be clear something is
happening today not in religious or
whatever which may affect the very
meaning status of being human a very
sensitivity spinning or ourselves
doesn't it imply I am here I think
realities out there the moment you can
which up to a certain extent they can
already do I think directly linked to a
computer you're thinking so that for
example you'd no longer even need the
famous Stephen Hawking but I told my god
in London I saw it myself they presented
machine for crippled I don't know what's
the politically correct term where you
just think forward and the machine moves
it's still very elementary but all these
plans granitic manipulations this is
what I see as the real problem not any
metaphysical nonsense of Nitra
zimmerman's something we'll probably
emerge and not talking anything great
which is in conflict with many of very
fundamental representations of what we
think is to be human and there are
problems here like maybe you know
Churchland husbands and wives the great
cognitivist couples they think that what
they call fault psychology our ordinary
notion of a stress-free being we'll just
before we
I have to accept that we are fully
biologically determined and so on but
there are many other positions so don't
you think something important is going
on you don't think no absolutely not
don't in this area here you are secretly
idealist because you think that we can
do all things we can do to our bodies
yes but sometimes we will we will remain
the same
yes there are many things that go wrong
with us where we don't remember in the
same you know you can have a mental
illness you don't remain the same but
that doesn't mean to say that everything
is coming clean slate for example if
true biological chemical manipulation
I can I can fundamentally in a serious
way affect your your physical properties
even your attitude your will to worsen
you don't have to gather if I could take
certain drugs and is only the beginning
if you know not to be guilty the
settling you think this will not affect
for example the whole pedagogy
falls away why should they learn and
when I can you know what I mean oh they
haven't got any way like that I also
have to contradict you
I am also biologists some some comments
what is absolute absolute is the fear of
death the fear of death is absolute and
I think you can see it in mother very
clearly so how do you counter the fear
of death by creating a god now that has
been through all the civilizations and
of course the evolution is like Louis or
like Richard rocking rocking even more
some of them will fight religion I don't
think it Lewis does it like Dawkins does
but Dawkins fights it very aggressively
now and that is again impossible because
as the great evolutionist see is the
Dawkins he does not realize that the
need to create a god in order to combat
the fear of death is absolutely built
into us by evolution that is also
absolute
and something about the absolute
absolute is the opposite of the polity
every slight eternity is the absolute
and Thurber allottee is the opposite we
are now here but we will we will not be
here in thousand in India yes this is
the eternities the return of eternity
with these things were for mana very
important this is change resting skill
in Christianity absolute intervenes in
time I don't speak I speak about about
annually so about philosophy philosophy
about the question of existence
existence what is this the existence I
don't have no idea what the absolute is
but I am a practitioner I am NOT a
philosopher and my I make my living as
minimal one by writing poems I solid
I'm empirical I read poetry when you
read poems from all the times you see
that half of the poems written not only
in the Western tradition our prayers
they have the form of a prayer it
doesn't mean that there's an absolute
I'm not claiming this it means that we
are first when they write they're mostly
by themselves are alone in their study
and in a meadow they don't need to be
witty like we need to be witty right now
but if you are an artist you're solitary
in your like mother was in his heart you
don't need to be witty and the natural
thing or the traditional thing is to say
a prayer too because you think there is
you you feel the presence there is
something else you
no idea what this something else is but
you address your words or your music to
something else so there is a tension
between you who are you after all you
don't have that much to say but in the
act of praying in a prayer there is an
and attention between what you are and
something else and that for me that's
very important is who am I about is a
crucial kind of a question I'd like to
focus our attention just on different
different kinds of problems as if we
talk about different kinds of knowledge
we get into big trouble getting the big
difficulties because they're there there
are considerable differences in our
views but think about problems what time
is it what day is it what's the cause of
AIDS
these these are sensible problems that
one can answer if I ask the question Who
am I as I did for the first time I
realized I became a philosopher I was 11
years old I was standing in front of a
mirror and asking myself okay
that's what I look like how do I know
how do I know that that's me and after
about 10 minutes I had lie down I mean
you just you just don't get an answer to
that question and and nobody else can
give me an answer to that question in a
way in which they can give me an answer
if I ask them what time is it or if I or
if I ask them what's the cause of a
particular disease now let's put this
into the context of Gustav Mahler
I'm thrice alienated as a check among
Austrians as an Austrian among Germans
as a Jew in the world so this question
for I mean if we want to understand
where Marla's going we should we should
ask where he's coming from he's coming
from
he's coming from questions like this
which which are very very hard to answer
in the most intelligent thing anybody
ever said about the problem of identity
is that it's a mystery and not a problem
referring to Gabriele Marcel because I
am part of the
question and I can't get out of myself
to answer that question so they're there
they're quite a long way sometimes with
luck with with the help of what of
philosophers no not Mehta physicians of
artists with the help of religion but
not all religion I'm in that that's the
real problem it's not the question of
art versus science is not the question
of religion versus enlightenment it's a
it's a question of what which form which
form of these bodies of knowledge are
available to me how can they help me